hey i'm kyra lead animator on the good
advice cup - hi I'm Mike character
animator on The Simpsons and today we
are gonna be dry Simpsons characters
from memory what is that bear you work
on The Simpsons
you're gonna make me look like good to
drive bad your character is sexy so glad
because I actually know who that is
feels like I'm wearing nothing at all oh
okay he's like kind of one of the more
normal looking dude doesn't he yeah I
feel like he has like a weird like shark
fin for a hairdo that's the main guy
yeah the guy that they based the
Simpsons off of and we better watch
ourselves because we have an animator
from The Simpsons here drawing with Kara
oh he's gonna look at her drawing so
he's gonna cruelly and unjustly judge us
his Instagram handle is I draw Homer
so Mike you've been working on The
Simpsons since 2004 how did you get that
job I was actually an intern after high
school I just did you know a lot of
intern solid work but slowly and slowly
I moved my way up to you know begging
artists for tips and like maybe I could
do a drawing and then one of their
scenes here and there and I just like
practicing and practicing until one day
I took the character animation test and
I passed it that's so cool I didn't grow
up watching you didn't know I feel like
everybody grew up watching this image I
kind of I have vague memories of the
Simpsons just being on TV everywhere
okay so like I'm in the laundromat
waiting but I never actually watched it
myself
really yeah let's see if I can just
manage doing the Simpsons style that's
another thing I don't draw like that
most of the time I feel like most of my
stuff has like a lot of volume and
construction to it or is there sort of
exists very much in a 2d plane I think
you're more volumetric than the sentence
well is there specific kind of volume
volumetric them oh this is yeah this is
close enough but it's not great you're
scared of the I love drawing homework I
am scared of the mics critique I'm not
gonna lie you're afraid of the animators
war army because which was he draws
homer for a living like that's what he
does you know what we do for a living
what we are wrong for a living the
internet we draw incorrectly for a
living on the internet we draw other
people's characters wrong so that people
can laugh at us hmm
so honestly so honestly we're doing our
job right doing our job if it's wrong
you know yeah yeah and a meme is
hamburgers steamed hams oh they're just
they're hams not ham it is it's
hamburgers but he's like up selling it
as steamed hams because he has like his
boss over for dinner
oh and sound like his meal goes to and
so he like runs across the street to get
hamburgers and it's like oh enjoy these
gourmet steamed hands so as an animator
on The Simpsons what's here like your
day to day routine look like so we have
scenes that we get from the board
artists and you know they set up the
shot they set up the composition our job
is to go in and add all the acting and
we get the audio track from the voice
actors and then we kind of go from there
I think we're like the last one that
actually does all that stuff everything
else like boards here's a fun fact about
Homer's design that I do know there is a
Hidden Mickey signature in his in his
head it is his hair is an M and his ear
looks like a G for Matt Groening
really that's really interesting cool I
will make his ear G now G for gamer G M
for mega and G for gamer mega gamer no
not right at all he's just wearing like
us he's wearing a suit right yes okay
the principle suit
principle a very principle hey wait am I
dressed are you dressed like him cody's
stand up
give me some reference and my dress
video yeah I Principal Skinner
first of all Skinner so Mike have you
met the voice actors from The Simpsons
yeah actually I went to a couple of
table reads which is you know they do
like a little rough run through the
script you know all the actors are there
there do their lives and their voice is
really awesome to see that's so cool and
they're extremely talented I hear you're
quite the voice actor yourself yes I am
Kevin what's your favorite episode of
The Simpsons so my favorite episode of
The Simpsons is called Lisa's substitute
it's a episode in the second season
where Lisa has a very inspiring teacher
who ends up going away because he's a
substitute teacher yeah but he gives her
the sweetest note in the world uh-huh
and tells her only look at it when you
are starting to doubt yourself and as he
goes away she opens it up and it says
you are Lisa Simpson but then my other
favorite episode is the one cute oh my
god you okay that was so cute and that
was just the synopsis yeah I know I lost
the episode should watch it oh my god
you guys like I'm a mess it's okay
sorry look at me deep breath deep
breaths whoa Oh didn't expect to cry in
the Simpsons episode
Cody how'd you do dead accurate I mean
this is basically on model yeah are you
applying to Simpsons right now I'm
probably gonna submit this yeah print
how did you do you also think you're
gonna get the job I think I'm gonna shoe
it at this point
hmm yeah they're bringing me on tomorrow
that's confident how do you think you
did on this one I try drawing a little
more on my style but I think I did
pretty good got pretty close to sexy
planners how about you
yeah the feel of them down how do you
think you did Kevin I think I did okay
so I feel like it's everything's just a
little bit off this Homer is part of the
off-brand character universe shown right
here I think I did pretty good just by
you know I I didn't really grow up
watching The Simpsons but I think I
understand the general look of Homer I
think I caught his essence I don't know
if it's accurate all right cool let's
take a look
oh yes now I feel like I should add a
color no yours is so beautiful it's like
a perfect sketch this is appealing I
like this I would eat those hamburgers
thank you oh my this is so it's pretty
impressionistic you didn't go for the
Simpson style this is very much a Kody
version of a Simpsons character I just
wanted to feel more nervous like he was
nervous about those steamed hands yeah
cuz that's all I remember is his anxiety
yes you did a pink donut which is the
iconic Simpsons donut yeah it's because
I went to the Universal Studios and they
were selling giant pink donut that's
like all I could think of I didn't I
didn't put the pink frosting yeah I love
his face so good I like the shiny but
you're gonna feel a nice touch yeah I
remember there was a helmet oh man okay
see there's that perfect like rectangle
body I just like I did this at some
point you could probably see sketches
over there somewhere
where I just was like use the line tool
just draw like a straight line down yeah
oh yeah no but you did like you got so
much right oh really hard but we got the
feel we got that yeah yeah look at this
rear 3/4 on Chalmers here yeah
and bizarre like I I got that he was
bald Wilmers guy oh yeah I don't know
you start drawing Chalmers I just uh I
drew that like homers I guess yeah well
thanks a lot for having me of course was
so nice to meet ya I had an awesome time
drawing trying to draw it was awesome
but I hear that Kevin Jackie are drawing
home right alright so I'm gonna go check
them out I'll see you later
Rohit's today are you ready Kevin ready
let's bring and Mike yeah first try Mike
how are you good thanks for joining us
hey how's it going so this is Jackie's
drawing of Homer okay you are somebody
who draws Homer for a living yes how on
or off model is Jackie strong it's a
beautiful drawing up model but I mean
it's really appealing so if you had to
do one or two things to make this a
little more on model
well definitely so I would oh okay Oh
picking up your dad Bart he's getting in
he's gift he's grading me like a just a
little longer okay he fixed your ear
mine I like the G in there though it's
mg mg for mega gamer yeah yeah exactly
yeah it's been confirmed been confirmed
on screen do you want to take a look at
my shirt okay Mike come on over on I'm
nervous I'm very nervous
don't be scared Kevin all he'll do is
say it's awful and draw over to make it
perfect wow this is like Homer Simpson
meets George Jetson okay so this is
again appealing oh here's the thing
about the muzzle how does it connect to
his nose because I feel like so it goes
from the bottom line of those okay and I
need a trick about the ear mm-hmm take
the bottom line of the eyeball and make
sure their body structure is yeah he's
like a little too tall and no Anatomy
the arm just a Gomez tooth it like yeah
they do have a rubber hose arms no I did
that at first it felt weird you know
what Kevin
this is why you need to believe in
yourself Jackie I do believe you need to
trust your gut like Homer has a gut am i
right Mike that's right
well Mike thank you for critiquing our
homers thank you Mike you are full of
magic
Mike this is why we can't have guests
Jackie that horrible to say totally yeah
we'll get out okay okay oh I'm sorry man
I apologize for all that I've done
[Music]